merci mon cher luc monsieur le président
nicolas sarkozy adressé ce matin la
feuille de route
notre feuille de route pour ce conseil
national le cap est clair la volonté
forte le cap de l'alternance la volonté
de changement merci à nicolas sarkozy de
porter avec le courage qui le
caractérise et la force qui l'habitent
cette espérance pour la france il est
temps il n'est que temps désormais de
définir notre ligne politique pendant
trop longtemps nos électeurs ont perçu
un décalage profond entre notre message
et leurs attentes
cet écart trouve sa source dans la
volonté sans doute trop abouti de
rechercher un consensus à n'importe quel
prix bien sûr ce consensus nous le
souhaitons comme garant de l'unité mais
il ne peut s'apparenter à la recherche
permanente du plus petit dénominateur
commun idéologique
nous ne gagnerons pas avec la prudence
nous gagnerons avec du courage
nous devons aujourd'hui retrouvé une
ligne droite droite pour éviter la
confusion voire les contorsions d'allah
d'alliance contre nature
d'où rate pour être fidèle à nos valeurs
fondatrices n'ayons pas honte d'être de
droite
ayons la fierté d'une droite qui
revendique la force et la pertinence de
ces valeurs je veux dire pour ma part ma
fierté d'être de droite
être de droite pour moi c'est dire que
nous n'avons rien à voir avec une gauche
qui a mis à genoux notre pays
être de droite pour moi c'est dire que
nous nous compromettrons jamais avec la
de gauche et que nous refuserons
toujours toute alliance avec le front
national
être de droite pour moi c'est considérer
que la france ne sera jamais
une mosaïque de région artificielle sans
histoire et sans âme mais que la france
sera toujours une nation une et
indivisible
être de droite pour moi c'est dire que
le travail aura toujours une valeur
supérieure à l'assistanat m de droite
pour moi et peut-être d'abord c'est dire
aussi que nous voulons restaurer
l'autorité républicaine
oui la france a besoin d'autorité les
français exigent ils la réclame
l'autorité d'un chef d'abord cher
nicolas sarkozy bref le contraire de ce
président de la république monsieur
hollande suppliant leonarda de revenir
en france où cédant au chantage des
verts à notre dame des landes
l'autorité d'un état qu'ils fassent
respecter les lois de la république
bref le contraire de ce gouvernement qui
recule à moirans ou sur l'autouroute 1
l'autorité d'un état
refusant qu'une jungle s'installe comme
à calais avec ses règles mafieuses sur
le territoire de la république
l'autorité de l'état c'est aussi la
capacité de pouvoir choisir le nombre et
la qualité de ce qu'il va accueillir sur
notre sol national
l'autorité de l'état c'est sa volonté à
faire aimer la france à transmettre
notre histoire et ses valeurs
ce n'est pas l'expression de la
repentance permanente
l'autorité de l'état c'est sa capacité à
assimiler
oui assimilés ceux qui veulent devenir
français ce n'est pas la nationalité
bras des données même à ceux qui
haïssent la france l'autorité de l'état
c'est sa capacité à combattre le
terrorisme sans naïveté en refusant sur
son territoire le retour de ceux qui ont
décidé de combattre notre nation avec
les armes
oui l'autorité de l'état c'est aussi la
capacité de l'école de la république
à ne pas placer l'élève sur le même rang
que le m l'autorité de l'état
c'est dire aux parents la nécessité
impérieuse d'un équilibre entre droits
et devoirs c'est ce qui m'avait conduit
à faire adopter à la demande de nicolas
sarkozy
une loi permettant de supprimer les
allocations familiales aux parents qui
n'en voyaient plus leurs enfants sur les
bancs de l'école de la république
alors oui c'est un autre famille qu'ils
appartiennent de restaurer cette
autorité perdu m de droite aussi mes
chers amis c'est pour moi et peut-être
surtout l'exigence de défendre notre
identité défendre notre identité c'est
garantir à chaque français la permanence
d'un mode de vie
fidèle à notre passé à notre culture
bref vouloir que la france reste la
france
oui je veux que la france reste la
france défendre notre identité c'est
lutter contre le communautarisme qui
divise la nation et nourrit les n1
communautarisme auquel tant de
socialistes socialistes se sont soumis
avec lâcheté et compromissions nous
devons pour cela
réaffirmer avec force le principe de
laïcité qui régit nos institutions
rajoutez à la devise de notre république
la liberté l'égalité la fraternité oui y
rajouter la laïcité serait pour moi
bienvenue la laïcité en effet c'est le
rempart contre l'obscurantisme
la laïcité c'est une digue contre les
fanatismes
car aucune loi religieuse ne peut et ne
doit être supérieure aux lois de la
république la religion catholique
au début du siècle dernier
c'est soumises à ce principe fondateur
l'islam de france doit s'y soumettre
aujourd'hui avec la même exigence
ce n'est pas la république de s'adapter
à de s'adapter aux règles de l'islam
mais c'est à l'islam de s'adapter aux
règles de la république
mon cher henri guaino pour moi ce n'est
pas l'école de la république et nous
aurons une divergence là dessus de
fournir des menus à la carte en fonction
des religions de chacun cependant
aujourd'hui j'ai la conviction que pour
être encore plus exigeants sur cette
laïcité
nous devons rappeler et ne jamais
oublier la force et la profondeur de nos
racines et de notre identité culturelle
le général de gaulle rappelé dans ses
mémoires d'espoir que la france viennent
du fond des âges
quelle vie que l'avenir l'appel et nous
venons que nous voulons que cet avenir
soit radieux pour nos enfants mais il
ajouté elle demeure elle même au long du
temps oui nous voulons que la france
demeure elle-même au long du temps pour
être plus fort mes amis face aux menaces
terribles face aux fanatiques qui nous
attaque
il est nécessaire d'exprimer encore plus
clairement le fait que si la république
française est bel et bien là hic si elle
ne reconnaît aucune religion d'état pour
mieux accorder à chacun une complète
liberté de croire et de pratiquer une
religion
la france elle est l'héritière d'une
culture et d'une civilisation chrétienne
c'est incontestablement cette dimension
qui a forgé notre organisation sociale
actuelle notre calendrier civil nos
modes de vie tout simplement
c'est pour cela que je souhaite pour ma
part comme le président giscard
d'estaing l'avait souhaité au moment de
la rédaction de la constitution
européenne
et là sans succès que l'on inscrive ses
racines chrétiennes dans notre
constitution
mes chers amis mes chers amis
après 4 en déliquescence à la tête du
pays par les socialistes
tant de sentiers sont amenés aujourd'hui
pour reconstruire cette france que nous
aimons passionnément cette france forte
que nous avait proposé nicolas sarkozy
porter haut ses valeurs ce sont celles
que les français attendent exige je vous
invite à les porter avec notre président
pour assurer le redressement de la
france
je vous invite à les porter autour et
derrière nicolas sarkozy